auf mallorca ist ein hassverbrechen das
unglück passiert ein elf monate altes
baby ist dort in einem pool ertrunken
offenbar während die eltern des kindes
schliefen und zu diesen tragischen fall
spreche ich jetzt mit meinem kollegen
jan lang hausen auf mallorca
hallo jan wie konnte dieses tragische
unglück passieren was weißt du genaueres
ja eh auf der insel ist man immer noch
fassungslos würde dieses tragische
unglück
es geschah in el toro das ist eine
gemeinde und 20 autominuten von hier an
der küste entfernt
das ganze soll in einem privathaus
passiert sein die eltern sollen
geschlafen haben als das elf monate alte
baby mit seinem dreijährigen bruder
spielte wohl in der nähe des pools und
wo es dann wohl reingefallen ist ja wie
gesagt es ist immer noch hier ist man
immer noch fassungslos darüber wie das
passieren konnte die genauen umstände
werden jetzt aktuell aber noch ermittelt
aus welchem land kommen die eltern und
wird auch gegen die eltern ermittelt
das ist noch unklar ob gegen die eltern
ermittelt wird und woher sie kommen auch
das wird sich jetzt erst in den nächsten
tagen zeigen
fest steht aber dass das kind noch
gelebt haben soll als es nach dem es in
den pool gefallen war nach denen die
eltern herbeigeeilt sind der bruder kam
ja angeblich zu den eltern hin hat sie
geweckt daraufhin sind die eltern zum
teil haben das baby herausgeholt und da
soll das baby noch gelebt haben und soll
ein tools noch gehabt haben
es wurde dann allerdings in das
krankenhaus hier gebracht dass man bei
mir im hintergrund sieht und verstarb
der tragischerweise eintritt